Taiwanese artist Xu Xiaoshun
He has suffered from gout for more than 30 years.
It can be said to be a living representative
of gout
Once he went to Macau to eat prawns
The next day
Gout attacks
feet hurt so much that can't even stand up.
Painkillers don't help.
Finally, can only use a wheelchair
Fly back to Taiwan
stayed in the hospital
for nine days before being discharged.
Want to avoid gout recurrence?
Come drink this cup
Reduce the risk of gout
will tell you in a moment.
Hu Naiwen starts his lecture
I'm your old friend, Dr. Hu.
I want to share this episode with you
Drinking one drink can reduce gout risk by 40%
Gout attack: 1 acupuncture point and 2 fruits to relieve pain
A bowl of Taiwanese snacks can lower uric acid, high blood sugar and high cholesterol.
Can you get gout even if you don’t eat seafood?
Drinking one cup reduces gout risk by 40%
Nearly one million people in Taiwan
suffer from gout
This number is really scary.
Want to prevent gout
Come drink a glass of milk every day
The New England Journal of Medicine states
People who drink dairy products every day
chance of getting gout
Can reduce
44%
But remind you
Don't drink milk too cold
Whey protein from milk
Allows uric acid to dissolve and be excreted smoothly
And its casein
Accelerate lactic acid excretion
Indirectly allows uric acid
to be excreted
Hey, a fan asked me
Doctor Hu
What if I don't drink milk?
It's okay for people who don't drink milk.
You eat sugar-free yogurt
Hey, that's OK
Is gout a disease
that only middle-aged people get?
no
Even elementary school students
are suffering from gout now.
Is this true? This is outrageous.
It's true. An eight-year-old boy
Eat braised pork rice frequently
Keep yourself plump and white
One day, was walking and suddenly became lame.
A checkup revealed that it
was a gout attack.
Also combined with other chronic diseases
It really makes me sweat.
Gout doesn't just happen to people
who love to eat a lot of meat and drink alcohol.
or obese men
should also pay attention to these two types of people
People who love to drink sugary drinks
Postmenopausal women
TheEditor
You drink beverages every day
You have to pay attention
Okay, doctor.
I'll drink
7 drinks a week.
Change to 6 and a half cups
Give half to colleagues
Wow
Drink less
Editor, do you know?
People who drink 500cc of sugary drinks every day
High fructose corn syrup
in sugary drinks
It will hinder the excretion of uric acid
After menopause, you haven't
Postmenopausal women
Because of the decline in estrogen
Uric acid metabolism slows down
Gout Risk
It will also increase significantly
Gout is not treated properly
What problems will we face?
Dialysis, washing the kidneys
Excessive uric acid can accumulate in joints
It makes you swollen and painful.
Over time, the kidneys also begin to be damaged.
If it's more serious
will probably
need dialysis.
At that time, it hurt my health and cost money
It takes a lot of time
Isn't it worth it?
Gout attack in the middle of the night?
1 acupoint to relieve pain and nourish the kidneys
Use these two methods to quickly eliminate gout
The first step
Wrap the ice in a towel.
Apply to swollen areas to relieve pain
The second move is to press 1 acupoint
What to press
Tài xī(transliteration)acupoint
Tài xī(transliteration)acupointis amazing
Acute gout
You press this acupoint
It relieves pain
In the chronic stage, pressingTài xī(transliteration)acupointcan nourish the kidneys
Where isTài xī(transliteration)acupoint?
Between the tip
of the medial malleolus and the Achilles tendon at the back
Inside that sunken hole
That is
You can press and listen to me now
I'll tell you slowly
Tài xī(transliteration)acupointis not only able to relieve pain
It has many effects
Can adjust kidney qi deficiency
Imbalance in uric acid metabolism
It is a very large acupoint on the kidney meridian.
You have gout
People with high uric acid
Massage this acupoint more often.
It can fundamentally adjust the kidney qi
Eliminate toxins from the body
Let gout no longer bother you in the middle of the night
2 fruits to relieve joint swelling and pain
Can drinking soy milk cause gout?
People with gout
Are you worried that drinking soy milk
and eating dried tofu will make gout worse?
don’t worry
其實是在急性期的時候
Cannot eat soy products
In the chronic stage
Tofu, Dried Tofu, Soy Milk
These are edible normally.
Come, I'll teach you.
What is the diet for acute and chronic gout?
Let you quickly stay away from gout
Let’s talk about the first part first
Acute phase
When you have severe joint pain
When gout attacks
Come and eat two kinds of fruit
1. 櫻桃 2. 藍莓
Cherries and blueberries
Contains phytochemicals and polyphenols.
Can reduce the formation of uric acid crystals
Anti-inflammatory
For joint pain
Very helpful
Research findings
Eat 10 to 12 cherries a day
Or a small bowl of blueberries
Probably a girl's fist
This size portion
can reduce gout
Risk of recurrence
But it doesn't mean the more you eat, the better.
Eating too much sugar is too high
What foods should not be eaten during the acute phase?
Stop eating these four types of food first
1. Meat
Like red meat
Such as beef, lamb, pork and other red meat
2. Seafood 3. Alcohol
4. High-purine foods.
Fish skin, dried small fish, and offal
There is also a very thick hot pot soup
Chicken soup
Also,
These vegetables
Pea sprouts, bean sprouts, asparagus, mushrooms, purple seaweed
Don't eat yet
These ingredients
Its nucleic acid content is relatively high
Easy to increase uric acid
Now let’s talk about the chronic phase
Your diet
You can slowly return to normal
However, the acute phase
Foods that cannot be eaten
Don't eat too much though.
Eat white meat, fish, eggs, and soy products
But remember
It’s better not to eat fried beans.
Avoid sweets, alcohol, and sugary drinks
Do you usually like spicy powder and pepper?
Sprinkle well and fully.
Love strong flavors
You make the taste lighter.
Reduce the burden on the kidneys
Finally, drinking water is also important.
Can drinking more water lower uric acid?
Can
Drinking more water can increase urine output
Accelerate the excretion of uric acid
Reduce the risk of uric acid deposits in joints
Helps control gout
1 bowl of snacks is amazing
Lower uric acid and the three highs.
Traditional Chinese Medicine for Gout
It can not only lower uric acid
It will also cure gout
The real problem behind
Gout is a problem with the spleen and kidneys
Phlegm and dampness accumulate in the body
Meridian blockage
The joints hurt so much
Want to prevent gout from recurring
Recommend you to drink Taiwanese snacks
Sì shén tāng(transliteration)
Sì shén tāng(transliteration)has 5 great benefits
1. Jiàn pí lì shī(transliteration)
2.Tōng jīng huó luò(transliteration)
3. Lowering uric acid
4. Strengthen the spleen and stomach
5. Reduce the three highs
Wow, that's great.
The recipe ofSì shén tāng(transliteration)is very simple
Poria cocos, Euryale ferox, lotus seeds, Chinese yam
Taiwanese shops sellingSì shén tāng(transliteration)
always add coix seed.
coix seedis the soul of this bowl of soup
Recorded in the Shénnóng běn cǎo jīng(transliteration)
coix seedcan treat muscle stiffness
Fēng shī bì tòng(transliteration)
Long-term drinking can make you lighter
healthier and stronger
I have a patient
78-year-old lady
Gout, high blood sugar, and high blood pressure
I suggest she drinkSì shén tāng(transliteration)every day
Two years later, gout no longer occurs
Blood sugar and blood pressure are stable
Greatly improved quality of life
Did you know
She was in his 90s
can still take the bus to see me
Another overseas audience
shared with me
He has high blood sugar
Feeling drowsy all day
People feel very uncomfortable
After drinking theSì shén tāng(transliteration)for a week
His blood sugar,
which had been unable to be lowered
actually dropped.
What is even more miraculous is
Blood pressure also dropped
People feel refreshed and energetic
It's really great, right?
If there are people with three highs in the family
You can drinkSì shén tāng(transliteration)two or three times a week.
Help you control blood sugar and blood pressure
Even children can drink it to nourish the spleen and stomach and protect the kidneys
There is a fan
Very cute message to ask me
Most of theSì shén tāng(transliteration)
They are all pig intestines and pig stomachs
People with gout
Isn't it forbidden to eat animal offal?
Isn't this contradictory?
That's right, Taiwanese snack shops sellSì shén tāng(transliteration)
Pig intestines and pig stomach are added
But
If you are a candidate for gout
Then cook theSì shén tāng(transliteration)yourself.
Don't buy ready-made ones like that.
Don't buy that ready-madeSì shén tāng(transliteration)made with pig intestines and pig stomach.
Leg swelling and pain may not be gout
Biàn zhèng shī zhì cái duì zhèng ó (transliteration)
I saw a patient before
This sick leg is red, swollen and painful.
Went to the hospital
The doctor has been treating him for gout.
have been treated for several weeks but it hasn't healed
And it hurts so much
Finally found me
I said as soon as I saw it
Well, this isn't it
This is cellulitis
So be careful.
Cellulitis and gout
A little bit similar
Gout mainly occurs on joints
Cellulitis
Often the skin is inflamed
Bacteria, etc.
Through tissue
Muscle tissue and move upwards
Become a whole line
or a whole piece of this redness, swelling, heat and pain
Because gout and cellulitis
look a lot like each other.
So the doctor's first impression
think this redness, swelling, heat and pain is gout.
But cellulitis is an infection
Anti-infective treatment
Wrong treatment will prolong the disease, right?
So don't think that the old gout problem is coming back.
Then I judged
Or talk to your doctor.
I have gout.
We who study Chinese medicine look at these things
We must make a good diagnosis
Treatment is effective
only when it targets symptoms
Dear fans,
We have opened the membership channel
If you agree with me promoting Chinese medicine
The concept of taking care of your own health
Small monthly donations are welcome
Just the price of two cups of coffee
Or become a VIP sponsor
With you
We can go further
Thank you so much